he deserves a victory lap he is the
director of the last dance
Jason hare joins us on the program good
morning Jason how you feeling I'm good
man how are you I'm good how does it
feel to exhale kind of surreal because
this is the first day that I haven't
literally had to worry about something
to do with the making of the show and in
at least two and a half years actually
well over that so yes it's a lot of
mixed emotions I was telling someone
last night that it's it's kind of like
how you feel when you graduate like a
high school or a college graduation you
know four years you say I can't wait to
get out of this place I can't wait and
then when that moment happens and you
look around you see you're not gonna see
these people again you're not gonna be
in a phase of your life like that again
I get sentimental in those times this
was a significant chapter of my life I'm
43 and I spent over four years on this
thing or almost four years and that's
about 10% of my life that I spent on
this story so it's uh it's definitely
bittersweet when's the last time you
spoke to Jordan when we interviewed him
in December oh so you haven't spoken to
him at all after this came out no I
don't have a relationship with him like
that no I've spoken to him you know a
handful of times my entire life and and
half of those or when we sat down for
cameras if I said you get one more
question to Jordan what would it be oh
that's a tough one we laughed at the end
of the the final episode or the final
interview we laughed because I said
anything you want to add and he said I
think we pretty much covered everything
and we both laughed a little bit I'd
have to think about that he put me on
the spot what's the story that you don't
think you got the full answer to mmm
well anything to do with Krauss of
course is you know I would love to know
if he regretted that that would be one
of my main questions is do you regret
saying to Phil Jackson you can go 80 to
a no and you're not coming back to to
coach this team because that was met
what made everything untenable
I believe if he doesn't say that if he
isn't draw a line in the sand like that
then Jerry Reinsdorf offers him another
year and he can still maybe make that
happen and if Phil makes it happen and
the rest of the team's gonna make it
happen you can argue about what would
have happened in that season to come but
um that's that's one that's always gonna
be kind of a blind spot for us because
we just don't have Jerry Krauss's
opinion on this did Carl Malone declined
to be interviewed yes
did he say why no he declined through
another party we asked him multiple
times did you try to reach out through
Stockton to Malone or yeah I figured
they were believing we exhausted just
about every avenue we started in January
of 2018 on that one because we knew that
he'd be a tough tough sell
and I tried right up until I think I
told you earlier this month that that we
interviewed John Stockton on March 10th
we were we were really up until the last
literally the last possible day to do
these interviews so we tried and tried
with Carl we tried to get them to sit
down together thought that might be a
better option it feel more comfortable
with that
but there was just no convincing it
anybody of note that aside from Malone
who said no Brian Russell yeah you know
what that wasn't and that was just a no
response
that was a we never got any anything
back from him and I think yeah I respect
to Brian I think he knew what questions
we were going to ask so maybe he didn't
want to go there but but there's there's
really nobody else of note that said
that declined you okay with the peach
the story now it's food poisoning not
the flu here Jase absolutely and I can I
can shed a little bit of light on that
as well okay so a lot of people I saw
online last night and people were
texting me asking like what kind of guy
eats an entire pizza in a room full of
grown men who doesn't grab a slice what
happened was that they're on the
outskirts of Salt Lake they're not
staying in in Salt Lake proper they're
they're kind of in the suburbs or on the
edge of town and there are limited food
options out there and at the time that
George and Gus and and Tim McGraw
actually Gus wasn't there but Tim Grover
and George and all the security guards
ordered dinner room service was working
men
and Michael wasn't hungry or he wasn't
there I think so he came back and he was
pissed off because they ate without him
so it gets to be about 10 11 o'clock and
he's hungry this is the story that he
told us so they find a place that that
delivers pizza and he says nobody
touched this pizza this is my pizza you
guys ate without me so he spat on the
pizza so that nobody else could eat it
and that's how we know that nobody else
bets now did he finish the pizza himself
I don't know but he did say that he spit
on the pizza so that nobody else could
eat it and I think he had been known for
doing this I heard her story sometime at
one time about how this is public that
he was on a commercial shoot and someone
gave him homemade brownies and his
security guards were in the trailer and
he said no one touched these brownies
these are mine and he spat on them and
went this chute so but he did tell us
that we didn't have time to put it into
the story but a lot of people said well
why would he eat an entire pizza that's
why I was told that he stayed in Park
City mm-hmm is that fair you said
they're on the outskirts of Salt Lake I
was told that Michael would stay in Park
City and not in Salt Lake City by
himself I don't know oki himself I don't
think he was staying with the team well
he was with the team though in 98 he
comes back to the hotel and he's with
the team so I know he stayed with the
team in Utah in 98 I'm not sure about 97
but I know we hammers there I think he
got the same suite every time he went to
Utah he would he would stay in the suite
that had that piano well that's why I
didn't know if he was you said he was on
the outskirts and then somebody said no
they stayed at the Marriott in downtown
Salt Lake which is not very far from the
arena but these are just details here
I'm trying to piece it all together
because I want to find out about this
pizza thing and what which security
allow five guys Jason to deliver a pizza
and the answer is no doubtful but I
don't know I don't know who was working
the door that I'm sure that I'm sure no
one called and said I don't I don't
think Michael called and said hi this
this is living legend Michael Jordan
could you deliver our large pepperoni to
my room I think it was the peaches going
up to room 522 and I there's a
conceivable world in which the guy work
in the front
Asche says the dudes hey that's Jordans
room that you're going to deliver a
pizza to I
I can't believe that there were five
guys working at a pizza joint on the
outskirts of Salt Lake City at one there
might be five Pizza RIA employees and
timezone at that point so you worked so
hard for four years and this is what I
want to ask you about yeah yeah I
expected it that's that's great if
there's no baseball strike what happens
to Michael Jordan I think he becomes a
major leaguer I think that he I think he
makes the White Sox that following year
and I think if he enjoys playing
baseball which I imagine he would have
if he doesn't get an itch too much to
come back to basketball that we're not
having this conversation because I think
that he would eat he could have finished
his career as a baseball player that's
my opinion I've been down this road in
the last five weeks or so that I say
that now all of a sudden it's a headline
that Michael Jordan would have played
that's my opinion that I I think that he
was passionate enough about baseball and
loved it so much and love that reset
that he got when he went to Birmingham
and I do firmly believe for myriad
reasons that he would have made the
major leagues including the fact that
none other than Terry Francona says he
needed a thousand more bats to get up
there did he address this the baseball
strike and what that meant to his
baseball career in his basketball career
I honestly forget I could look it up
right now
but I do know that that the baseball
strike left a sour taste in his mouth
there's no way he was gonna cross that
picket line he was not gonna be a scab
he knew that and I don't think he had
any intentions of going back to
basketball that year he was firmly
committed because he was he had hit I
think 268 in the fall we hit 202 for
Birmingham then he went to the Fall
League and had to 68 or 264 he was
improving and he was really excited for
that season and then what happened
happened so he didn't he was left really
with no choice but to leave baseball and
either retire from sports altogether or
come back to the Bulls I mentioned this
last hour and it caught some people
off-guard I said there was part of me
that felt sorry for Michael Jordan and
that is this is who he is every day we
admire it from afar he he lives in this
world where everything is competition
back then
everything I don't know how much he
enjoyed it as much as it was a relief
when he won the expectations were so
high I don't know if he could treat his
teammates any differently and I think
that's when he said the time he sat down
with you and he started to cheer up
let's break he didn't want to think
that's just not who he is he doesn't
allow himself to think that way did you
do you understand what I'm saying that I
felt sorry for him in some regards
because the people around him back then
it mod Rashad and Quinn Buckner and then
the security people that he pays to be
around him I just think he lived in this
world that we could never understand
relate to and you have the great scene
where he's on the couch with the cigar
knee who's here
this is my life here yeah it was a
tragic success that's a question of uber
Fame right I mean that yeah that's
that's separate from the torture of
being that competitively driven that
you're kind of held hostage by that
insatiable goal to win win win and I
think that there's probably people who
have similar I don't know if we call the
pathology but but similar mindsets that
are there must be maddening to live
within it's the fame to me that if I had
any sympathy for Michael it would be
because of that and that you know I
don't know that he I don't know that
anyone knew what kind of a prison he was
putting himself in when he became that
famous
at just that time there's so many
aspects to this story that couldn't have
happened in any other time Michael was
born in 1963 he turns 21 and joins the
NBA in 1984 at the same time that David
Stern comes on as new Commissioner this
visionary executive who may be the
greatest commissioner ever comes in at
the same time as Michael at the same
time that satellite and cable TV start
proliferating all over the country and
all over the globe at the same time that
were modifying American pop culture all
over the planet at the same time that
black Americans black entertainers are
being welcomed into homes so all of a
sudden it's Eddie Murphy and Bill Cosby
and prints in Michael Jackson or this is
something that couldn't have happened
ten years earlier so many of those
things happen in addition to that was
the proliferation of
electronic tabloid journalism so you had
hard copy and Inside Edition and these
kind of shows it was kind of like the
the prequel to TMZ culture and Michael
was it caught up in that Maelstrom and
if this had happened ten years earlier
maybe he's Magic Johnson and he's not
you know on gigantic murals halfway
around the globe he's he's just a
national star every single thing
happened for better or worse everything
happened exactly at the right time for
the stories he became what it was to
become it was what's the next project I
don't know I'm getting that question a
lot I don't know and I was joking to you
a while back that I need just a nap and
a cold beer and I still need that last
night was the late night just cuz the
the adrenaline and I heard from a lot of
people after the show and zoomed with my
family for about an hour afterwards and
and you know that that was a way of
bringing us together because of course
you know like all families we missed the
hell out of each other right now so I
haven't gotten a chance to really sit
back and think about anything else this
is really the first day where I haven't
been actively working or worrying about
this series because for better or worse
now it's done there's nothing I can do
about it it's out there now it's out in
the world what about the eleventh
episode we talked about this a couple of
weeks ago I would love to have Andy
Thompson who was you know part of the
genius behind all of this
let him talk about I just think the
people behind the scenes in gathering
all of this knowing that it might not
ever air and that you're getting this
stuff you know and we didn't hear the
stories of what they were shooting they
kept it quiet there I don't know
outtakes would be great I would like to
know when Michael said break what was
Jordan like after he became emotional
talking about the way he is to his
teammates when he got up what happened
next
he composed himself really quickly we
had a couple a couple of his people were
there I can tell you that a mod was was
was there a mod had come with him
because they had golfed earlier in the
day and in there of course really close
friends and I remember a mod like
Michael was composing himself in a mod
from the corner of the room said kill or
be killed and he started laughing I
don't think he realized cuz he couldn't
see me
Michael Michael was blocked by lights
and cameras and things so I I don't
think that he could realize that Michael
was getting emotional and I think that
he thought that Michael just got tired
or had to get up for some reason so he
was joking off-camera in there so that
immediately put Michael at ease and you
know he took a puff of the cigar and sat
back down we rolled pretty quickly and
the thing was - I know that you've seen
this side of him is that he snapped
right back into it and he started just
busting the balls of one of our camera
guys who was wearing shorts and had huge
calves
he got big calves man you play football
it was a good friend of mine John wrote
she said no basketball he goes off this
big slow white kid man and everyone
burst out laughing you know we're right
back into that charismatic Michael so he
knows how to flip the switch so the
headline here is Michael's spit on the
pizza so the guys in the room kind of
want that to be the headline no no you
don't want it to be what you got no
control that is that in fact is that
headline
[Music]
hey it was fun I hope you are able to
sit back and enjoy it sometimes you get
so close to it that it sort of takes
over your life but it was his story well
told there and you you should really
feel good about yourself there Jason
thank you man I appreciate it
thank you for your time go have that
beer and get that and have the nap and
then the beer or have the beer then the
NAB Chase awaits all about noon and I'll
make it the same all right
that's Jason here he's the director of
the last dance